en otros vídeos hemos hablado de la idea
de la discriminación de precios y en
este vídeo vamos a tratar de clasificar
las diferentes formas en las que una
empresa puede involucrarse en la
discriminación de precios como repaso
del concepto recordemos que se refiere a
cuando una empresa cobra precios
diferentes a consumidores diferentes
para así poder obtener lo más posible
del excedente del consumidor en otros
vídeos hemos visualizado esto mostrando
el excedente del consumidor y como una
empresa podría tratar de acceder a la
mayor parte de éste ahora hablemos de
los diferentes tipos de discriminación
de precios el primer tipo se conoce como
primer grado también conocida como
discriminación de precios perfecta y es
el tipo más teórico de los que vamos a
ver aquí en la discriminación de precios
perfecta o de primer grado la empresa
puede capturar esencialmente todo el
excedente del consumidor al cobrar a
cada individuo exactamente lo que está
dispuesto a pagar para poder lograr esto
tendríamos que saber mágicamente lo que
alguien está dispuesto a pagar
alguien se presenta a comprar le dicen a
ti te voy a cobrar cinco pesos porque de
alguna manera al leerle la mente saben
qué es exactamente cinco pesos lo que
quiere pagar y cuando llega la siguiente
persona le dicen a ti te voy a cobrar
cuatro pesos porque saben que eso es
exactamente lo que está dispuesto a
pagar en el mundo real no podemos llegar
a ese nivel de precisión pero las
empresas tratarán de llegar a esto ahora
un principio general que tiene que
cumplirse para que ocurra cualquier
discriminación de precios es que los
diferentes usuarios no deben saber lo
que las otras personas pagan y tampoco
deberían de comerciar entre ellos
este principio asociado a la
discriminación de precios es no
arbitraje el arbitraje es una palabra
sofisticada para evitar que ocurran
cosas como el que una persona compre
algo por cinco pesos aquí y pueda
venderlo a 7 pesos por acá que sería
algo muy natural de hacer si hubiera una
empresa que realice discriminación de
precios de primer grado y las personas
se enterarán al respecto entonces
podrían decir a ver
tú qué estás dispuesto a pagar cinco
pesos por ese objeto y es lo que te lo
vendería la empresa
yo voy a comprar ese objeto en tres
pesos porque es lo que estoy dispuesto a
pagar y es a lo que me lo venderá la
empresa y ahora yo te lo vendo a ti en
cinco pesos evitando que se lo compre a
la empresa es decir es una reventa así
que para que ocurra la discriminación de
precios en general pero sobre todo la
discriminación perfecta o de primer
grado es necesario que no haya arbitraje
el siguiente tipo de discriminación de
precios se conoce como segundo grado
vaya sorpresa y en esta situación una
empresa va a cobrar diferentes precios a
diferentes personas con base en la
cantidad que estas personas van a
comprar quizás ya se hayan dado cuenta
de que a veces hay descuentos al comprar
por volumen esta es una forma de
diferenciar hasta cierto punto este tipo
de discriminación de precios pero es
poco probable para la empresa capturar
todo el excedente del consumidor por
ejemplo un gran contratista que necesita
comprar una gran cantidad de madera y
que quizá no esté dispuesto a pagar
completo así que se le hace un descuento
con base en el volumen mientras que al
comprador común le cobran más debido a
que compra poca cantidad aquí estamos
hablando de precio contra cantidad y
ahora pasamos a o sorpresa la
discriminación de precios de tercer
grado y en este tipo de discriminación
se buscan ciertas características del
consumidor o mejor dicho en las
características del comprador el ejemplo
clásico de la discriminación de precios
de tercer grado es la diferencia de
precios en los boletos de un museo con
base en la edad de los asistentes un
precio para personas de la tercera edad
otro precio para niños y otro precio
para adultos la razón por la que hacen
esto es porque quizá las personas de la
tercera edad no están tan dispuestas a
pagar pero queremos que entren de todas
formas quizá lo hagan por otras razones
también quizá por buenos valores
sociales o algo así pero por definición
es una forma de discriminación de
precios porque se da un precio diferente
a personas diferentes con base en
quiénes son en el mundo real las
empresas tratan de hacer una combinación
de estos tipos de discriminar
de precios y también pueden variar un
poco por los mismos productos ya que
éstos no son homogéneos